[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
des questions au gouvernement de ce
mardi 14 avril des questions au
gouvernement qui interviennent au
lendemain de la prise de parole du
président de la république
emmanuel macron qui a annoncé une date
probable de début de déconfinement pour
le 11 mai prochain avec un retour
progressif à l'école mais des
inquiétudes demeurent comment ce retour
s'organisera t-il
c'est la députée brigitte kuster et lui
les républicains de paris qui pose la
question
la réouverture annoncée des crèches
écoles collèges et lycées
bien qu'elle soit nécessaire inquiète
légitimement de nombreux parents alors
que les enfants sont souvent des
vecteurs asymptomatiques du virus
quels arguments scientifiques justifie
ces réouvertures sur l'ensemble du
territoire
pourquoi ouvrir en premier les écoles
que vous aviez pourtant fermé en premier
et êtes vous prêts monsieur le premier
ministre en fin organiser un vrai débat
sur ce sujet devant la représentation
nationale je vous remercie
miss de l'éducation nationale a eu
l'occasion de dire que ce déconfinement
progressif
il se traduirait peut-être peut-être par
une forme adaptée de réouverture des
écoles
je ne veux sur ce point rien annoncé de
définitif puisque nous sommes en train
de travailler mais je n'exclus pas assez
vrai qu' on puisse envisager à partir du
11 mai que les écoles fonctionnent de
façon un peu différente de celle de la
façon dont elle fonctionne normalement
puisque par définition nous ne sommes
pas dans une période normale et chacun
peut l'apprécier mais pour pouvoir dire
cela précisément et je comprends
l'impatience vous la formule est d'une
certaine façon et une l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens la partage nous devons
étudier dans le détail avec l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés
la meilleure façon d'organiser une
logistique complexe de protéger nos
concitoyens de garantir leur sécurité
sanitaire ce sont véritablement les
principes qui nous guide et sa demande
en effet du travail de préparation
la vérité c'est que le président de la
république il l'a dit hier clairement a
demandé au gouvernement de préparer un
plan complet de sortie un plan
d'ensemble
j'aurai l'occasion de le présenter quand
il sera prêt largement avant
la date du 11 mai mais il doit être
travaillé il doit être aussi travaillé
en consultation avec beaucoup d'acteurs
pour être véritablement à la hauteur des
enjeux
les annonces du président sont elle
guidés par des préoccupations
économiques c'est ce que craint alexis
corbière député la france soumise de 500
go quels outils allez vous utiliser pour
éviter la propagation
demain massive d'une deuxième épidémie
dont les risques seraient importants
pourquoi n'allez-vous pas généraliser
les tests sérologiques dont vous ne
parlez pour tous à commencer par ceux
qui sont invités à reprendre leur
activité professionnelle pourquoi
limiter des tests à ceux qui présentent
des symptômes nous savons tous que l'on
peut être porteur du virus de façon
asymptomatique
on a le sentiment que vous répondez à
une injonction de la part de mes neuf
qui nous dit business d'abord alors que
l'aspiration des français c'est santé
d'abord monsieur corbières sachez qu'en
aucun cas il ne s'agit de suivre une
logique purement économique
contrairement à ce que laisse entendre
le raccourci que vous faites entre deux
segments de phrases qui ont été
prononcés par le président la république
parce que je les bien écouter le
président la république hier il a
commencé par parler des inégalités
insupportables les inégalités sociales
du corps bien je suis sûr que vous êtes
sensible à cet argument
il a aussi parlé du rôle fondamental de
l'école pour la formation
l'apprentissage des enfants pour leur
permettre d'évoluer en société je suis
sûr que vous êtes sensible à cet
argument massue corbières et puis il a
parlé aussi la nécessité de pouvoir
rendre à des personnes dans la société
la possibilité de retrouver une
perspective
oui de développement social économique
et demain culturel il a également dit et
premier ministre a répondu tout à
l'heure ce qui ne serait exclue d'emblée
de la reprise du pays or 11 mai des
activités tels que les restaurants les
bars etc
donc il a posé un cadre un cadre général
il a posé une date et j'entends ici que
tout le monde a salué le cap donné par
le président de la république enfin sur
la question des tests et symptômes j'ai
déjà répondu deux fois
si vous testez tout le monde un jour
donné admettons vouziers 60 millions de
tests pcr affaires et prélèvements ça ne
dit rien de l'état
c'est le de l'état de santé des
personnes que vous avez testé le
lendemain autres thèmes évoqués lors des
questions au gouvernement cet après-midi
l'incertitude économique des territoires
ultramarins la nouvelle calédonie
la polynésie française sont elles aussi
touchées par l'épidémie de coronavirus
et craignent de ne pas pouvoir venir en
aide à leur entreprise c'est là qu'elles
sont portées aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle par jean christophe lagarde
le président du groupe u10 agir et
indépendant au plan économique la
nouvelle calédonie et la polynésie
française doivent signer prochainement
les prêts de trésorerie garantis par
l'état permettant notamment
l'indemnisation des chômeurs mais ces
prêts conduiront l'endettement de ces
collectivités à un niveau extrêmement
élevé qui ne leur permettra pas de
financer des plans de relance économique
qui s'imposeront puisque contrairement à
l'état ces collectivités locales ont
l'obligation elle de présenter des
budgets en équilibre au titre de la
solidarité nationale le gouvernement
peut-il s'engager à transformer ses
prêts en concours financier exceptionnel
accordé à ces territoires ce que la
france fait pour 70 millions de français
peut-elle le fait le faire pour les 600
mille de nos concitoyens du pacifique
très tôt nous avons pris la décision et
comment reptiles peut en aller autrement
de faire jouer pleinement la solidarité
nationale à l'égard de nos concitoyens
d'outre-mer ce que je veux vous
confirmer
monsieur le président la garde c'est que
le projet de loi de finances
rectificative qui sera présenté demain
en conseil des ministres et qui viendra
à l'examen en séance vendredi à
l'assemblée nationale contiendra en
effet une disposition permettant à
l'état de garantir les emprunts
consentis par le territoire de nouvelle
calédonie afin de mettre en place un
dispositif équivalent au chômage partiel
tel que nous le connaissons en métropole
7 tout sauf anecdotique puisque cela va
permettre au territoire dans l'exercice
de sa compétence et sans se substituer à
lui ce qui est important quand même
peut-être encore plus important en
nouvelle calédonie qu'ailleurs ça va
permettre à la nouvelle qualifie de
mettre en place un dispositif nouveau
qui va accompagner la vie poser la
question de savoir si cette garantie
d'emprunt doit être transformé le moment
venu dans quelque chose qui relèveraient
au fond d'eux du financement direct par
la collectivité
des dispositions mises en place par le
territoire de nouvelle calédonie pense
que cette question devrait être abordée
mais qu'il est prématuré de le faire
aujourd'hui
comment les professionnels du tourisme
vont ils réussir à se relever après le
confinement le député liberté et
territoire françois pupponi souhaite un
plan de sauvetage pour les secteurs les
plus impactés par la crise entre le plan
d'urgence et le plan de relance que vous
nous proposez que vous mettez en oeuvre
il manque à votre arsenal un plan de
sauvetage pour les secteurs les plus
impactés ceux concernés par plus de
quatre mois de fermeture l'hôtellerie la
restauration la culture et
d'événementiel certes le président elle
évoqué hier est une bonne chose
un plan spécifique mais qu'il est urgent
de préciser plusieurs questions sur ce
plan comporte at il des annulations de
charge des aides pour les loyers et sur
la méthode
allez-vous faire le choix de concerter
les acteurs économiques les
organisations les parlementaires mais
aussi les collectivités territoriales et
locales en effet souvent n'avaient
territoires ruraux ce sont elles qui
depuis des années ont permis à ces
petits commerces de voir le jour et de
survivre nous avons élargi les
conditions d'accès des entreprises qui
ont des situation financière fragile de
façon à ce qu'elle puisse elle aussi
avoir accès à ces dispositifs c'est une
négociation que nous avons eues avec
l'union européenne et c'est ce sont des
éléments que vous allez être amenés à
voter dans les prochains jours je vais
également dire que nous avons activé une
enveloppe d'un milliard d'euros 1
milliard d'euros 2 dess vous connaissez
ce dispositif il était à 75 millions
d'euros
auparavant il est aujourd'hui élargie
pour accompagner plus massivement les
entreprises en difficulté et surtout
pour accompagner les plus petites
d'entre elles puisque nous allons
déléguer une partie de cette enveloppe à
nos directs à nos services régionaux qui
comme vous le savez travaillant très
bonne intelligence avec les
collectivités locales au premier chef
les régions qui sont à la manoeuvre sur
le développement économique et qui
d'ores et déjà ont prévu des mesures
pour accompagner ces entreprises
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement de ce mardi 14 avril
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine